peu
[Musique]
on disait chez nous la drôle de guerre
la vraie dans toute son horreur
comment ça pour la france le 10 mai 1940
ce jour-là hitler déclenché l'offensive
générale sur le front de l'ouest
la hollande et la belgique sont en
veille le 13 à notre tour
poussant devant eux un immense flot de
réfugiés les blindés allemands france
vers le sud le 7 juin les panzer
division approche de roi le 12
elbeuf mende senlis et reims tombe au
pouvoir de l'ennemi le 14 la wehrmarcht
entre à paris
le sait
elle atteint angers tours orléans
neubert le 17 appelé depuis la veille à
la tête du gouvernement
le maréchal pétain annonce en français
qu'il faut cesser le combat
le 22 juin 1940 à 19h15 dans cette même
clairière de rethondes et dans ce même
gbagbo ou 22 ans plus tôt le 11 novembre
1918 s'était consacré la défaite de
l'allemagne avait rial la convention
d'armistice et signé l'un des articles
de cette convention stipule que les
trois cinquièmes du territoire français
seront occupés par l'armée allemande
une frontière va couper la france en
deux la ligne de démarcation
partant de la frontière espagnole elle
passe à l'est de saint-jean-pied-de-port
par orthez mont-de-marsan et langon elle
s'appelait chi légèrement à l'aise de
libourne angoulême et poitiers traverse
le cher à bléré près de tours puis de
vierzon rejoint moulin franchi la loire
remonte vers le jura les cinq lui
revendre sous de dole pour redescendre
près de gex jusqu'à la première sus
la ligne comporte des points de passage
officiel strictement contrôlé où les
privilégiés qui ont reçu des autorités
d'occupation la permission d'aller de
zones occupées en zone libre ou
inversement présentent leur house weiss
bien entendu cette adresse ou
laissez-passer ne s'obtient qu'au prix
de multiples démarches et
d'interminables attente est encore dans
des cas bien déterminé présentant un
caractère d'urgence
c'est pourquoi ceux qui ne disposait pas
d'un house baisse je veux dire les
prisonniers évadés par exemple les juifs
pourchassés par la gestapo mes camarades
des réseaux de résistance les familles
poussées par l'exode jusqu'au sud mais
qui désiraient rentrer chez elles eurent
recours à des habitants du voisinage de
la ligne qui connaissant bien la contrée
était à même de la leur faire franchir
clandestinement
il y eut des gens à profiter des
circonstances pour en faire un commerce
fructueux allant parfois jusqu'au vol ou
même jusqu'à l'assassinât
ceux là n'ont pas droit au titre de
passeur les passeurs que j'ai connus
furent tous d'un dévouement d'un courage
d'une injection d'une générosité
exemplaire
beaucoup ont payé leurs actions de leur
vie les aventures qui vont se dérouler
sous vos yeux ont été vécus je les ai
rapporté telles qu'elles m'ont été
compté par leurs témoins et parfois même
par leur héros
[Musique]
c'est par les bords du cher que nous
allons commencer
plus de trente mille personnes se
présentaient au petit village de tennis
afin d'éviter le contrôle du poste
allemand qui était installée à vierzon
la région était constamment parcouru par
des patrouilles de douaniers souvent à
cheval
[Applaudissements]
ah voilà voilà
cindy fabre au boulanger pain grotte
qu'est ce qu'il ya là du doigt route
merci
oh
[Applaudissements]
voyez vous comme ça les gars on se
promène promener ouais soyez pas plutôt
des s'évader qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire ça croyez que ça soit pas bon ça
soit comme le nez au milieu de la figure
vous cherchez à passer de l'autre côté
on aimerait oui c'est comment vous y
prendre
c'est à dire adresse et bonne chance et
là attention faites vous pas tardé pour
la patrouille
je la croisais les palois patrouille
vous savez ici
balala alors si jamais vous entonnez à
vos deux chevaux ou plan qu'ils ont
c'est un fossé ou dans les mêmes et dit
c'est embêtant ça parce que quand on a
justement de quoi nous qui sont avant je
sais pas dû pouvoir écouter
planquez-vous mois moi je sais des ailes
à tous d'aller prévenir loquet
enfin un petit plus haut
conduire en veine des tirets le terrain
de braga
mr
messieurs je voudrais parler à monsieur
toupet qui travaille à la gare de
thénioux pas seulement besoin de vous
faire un dessin
vous venez d'où salak 12 à côté de
coblence
qu'est ce qui vous a donné mon adresse
c'est un copain à moi qui s'est évadé du
stalag les trois mois et il a passé la
ligne ici il s'appelle la news vous dit
rien
comportement et il m'avait dit que s'il
réussissait il mais féret pour mener
tuyaux j'essaie d'en faire autant il
devait bien enveloppé ça que si c'était
des nouvelles de la famille les proches
qui ont vu que du feu et dans les
lettres il disait que le cousin toupet
travail à la gare de teigneux pas dire
sans ça voulait dire qu'on pouvait
compter sur eux
[Musique]
ça l'est pas nous laisser tomber
vous allez nous aider mon copain et moi
mon frère qui passera ce soir en
attendant venez vous cacher dans la
lampisterie
oui toi aussi
merci
vous inquiétez pas ce boulanger sommes
là mais qu'est ce que t'as foutu mais
j'ai pas bu n'ya plus tôt le trajet
entre on a tu tombe bien on est 14e
il reste la seule côte sont justement
marcenat je voulais dire je suis bien
embêté d'une descente du contrôle
économique sans lui dirai film en stock
de farine ils sont aperçus que je gêne
mais aussi je bois continue encore
longtemps
bah question quand tout ce qu'on demande
aux soins alors ben voilà mes deux
gaillards michel viens de vous retrouver
ici
mais vos profs copains oui c'est un vous
avez passé s'il a décimé salut raymond
savard est en baisse
il est toujours chez sa grand mère
renault ça va avec lui vous êtes en
bonne heure ces droits des poissons
qu'est ce que c'est bon t'as pas suivi
vraiment caché dans la rue derrière du
texte comme si tu mangeais
[Musique]
nous sommes monsieur excusez nous de
vous déranger ce monsieur bourdin qui
nous envoie nos enfants sont tellement
me sens voudrait bien les revoir
seulement elle n'a pas pu voir 2000
s'est passé alors on s'est dit tant pis
on va tenter le tout pour le tout
d'après trân merrill a de l'argent est
là dans un café et un monsieur qui nous
a dit moi je peux vous faire passer la
ligne c 2 1000 francs par personne
on en avait trois nuls il a quand même
accepté alors il hier soir il nous a
conduit jusqu'aux bords du cher
là il nous a dit attendez moi que la
plante du vieux comme ça on doit les y
balancer mon cher c'est à l'auberge
qu'on nous a indiqué notre maison les
zombies le feu seulement comme les goûts
salés nous demandez vous savez si chacun
donne comme il peut celui qui a rien il
donne rien
avant la guerre raymond toupet était
serrurier à vierzon démobilisés à
bourges il accepta tout de suite d'aider
les gens à passer en zone libre
arrêté une première fois condamnée il
avait jugé préférable à sa sortie de
prison de venir s'installer chez son
frère atteignons et depuis se consacrer
entièrement à sa tâche de passeurs
c'est là et à votre barque
tu crois que je vais d'abaisser les
notes angers d'ottawa d'aller noyer en
ce que vous avez à l'attirer
hu
allez
oui
[Musique]
où
oui
[Musique]
nous
non non pas de bruit les gars parce que
l'on peut vous entendre de votre côté 1
puis moi j'y retourne vous voyez la
ferme à la grosse truite de fondre ouais
vous y est attendue pour les proposer
avant de repartir
merci n'en sais rien mais jour se lève
il faut gens peuvent avoir
[Musique]
mais
l'ept qui suce pour l'évolution il vous
faut bien un peu d'argent pour payer le
train
bonne chance
les choses ne se passaient pas toujours
aussi bien et lui quelque chose à
l'herbe
l'enfant rien de grave au moins jusqu'en
quarts des
[Musique]
il y en marre sénat encore un client
pour toi on évadé à ce qui me gêne un
petit rouquin
c'est ce que je me suis dit je vais voir
je désire et on peut parler ici
oui pourquoi pas je m'appelle tournée
elle m'a dit vous pourriez m'aider à
passer entre niveaux qui vous en essonne
vous avez enseigné pas ce boulot là
pourtant asiatiques je suis content que
ça y est me suis jeune et beau jeu mes
trousses et puis je suis donc bien vous
pouvez avoir confiance
la grèce a encore une fois je fais pas
ce boulot là j'étais si je pique [ __ ]
leur race holstein au fait recevoir la
maison je reviens un petit rouquin avec
une canadienne je le vis avec les autres
lire alain bournazel chef ne m'avait pas
retenu à la gare mais pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya je sais pas mais ce type là il
ferait partie de la gestapo sur
m'étendrai pas recours oui d'abord une
dit qu'il évalue et puis après que les
cheminots le morceau permis d'être que
de la semaine dernière alors donc je me
le faire on n'engage pas des prisonniers
évadés
la preuve qui m'a menti non bon c'est
bien fou au revoir des espions partout
quand même d'accord temps d'un chien qui
si ça fait plus d'un mois que je sens
qu'on ait repéré des je te ferai pas dit
lo'jo révèle une bonne femme la
kommandatur pourra laisser passer puis
je pouvais pas d'avoir tout de suite et
les termes étaient elle interprète lui a
dit donnez moi cinq cents francs et je
vous donne une adresse au pourra vous
aider
passer d'un autre qu'il a donné à la
pêche mais c'est de l'argent sur nantes
2 millions et c'est elle que ça non je
crois bien qu'aux frais mais d'arrêter
moins pour quelques temps
mais d'un autre côté on peut pas laisser
les gens dans mon bar temps là combien
ce soir nous sera du voyage
ce qu'il y a
je croyais avoir entendu des bruits
finirai mon couplet
si j'avais un hommage à mon petit jeu
c'est bien ce que je ferai la zone de
libre je la travaille très vite aux 8
je passerai d'espagne et puis dans l'âme
angleterre et je continuerai à me battre
contre limoges est parée d'or c'est
peut-être ce que tu comptes de fernand
non je vais me planquer simon la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
audio il y apparaît tantôt frère un non
pas tant d arriver à l'amérique devrait
déjà trop tard
coutu
la personne ne bouge bien sûr la tête je
me dis que ça donne et la voilà cela
vous fait alors monsieur toupet vous
fait le passeur avec votre frère vous et
votre frère quoi vous n'avez pas eu
réponse et nous savons qu'ils se cachent
par ici il est revenu par ici va bien et
on fait tout étudiant s'est tapé devant
se tenir
où est la clé du grenier
aller le chercher j'adore aussi bien
voté les avoir laissé échapper tous les
deux
une heure plus tard ils étaient en zone
libre et il frappait à la porte de son
ami du puits oh non c'est toi tu as
réussi à t'en sortir
c'est à pas vraiment s'il est là
voilà je me suis fait un bond récent dit
non c'est bien que tu te laisserai pas
quoi c'est comme ça qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on s'est fait choper le long du
canal
j'ai bien plonger dans l'eau mon direct
sur une balle dans la jambe
alors comment tu fais pour venir jusque
le plus dur c'était pour aller jusqu'aux
cher parce que je pouvais pas marcher
eh ben j'ai juste avec moi
ce tome on n'en sait rien docteur chézy
lui a fait un pansement mais ladite
demain pourrait l'amener à l'hôpital
les autres la maison ils ont tous été
pris aussi ma faute j'ai pas été assez
méfiants les noms tard et être reprochée
va on a fait ce qu'on a pu
bien entendu les deux frères ne revient
plus à thénioux la gestapo à emile en
tête à prix 100 mille francs une somme
considérable pour l'époque et apposé une
affiche sur la porte de leur maison afin
que nul n'ignore les chèvres soufre est
elle aussi des restrictions ou
sont-elles friande de papier toujours
est il que lui n'en fit ses délices les
allemands ne voulurent jamais admettre
cette version des faits est mis en
demeure le maire du pays de faire
assurer la garde de la maison jour et
nuit montaient la garde pour des chèvres
[ __ ] de guerre
on aura tout vu
les semaines passèrent raymond se
remettait lentement de sa blessure mais
l'inaction lui peser surtout il
souffrait de ne plus pouvoir aller
embrasser son fils resté en zone occupée
l'alsacien alors voilà je te fais la
commission parce que j'ai promis de
telles affaires mais moi ta place je
dirais non
il a besoin oui c'est une famille de
juifs qui débarque de paris alors ils
les emmènerait sur l'autre rive vrai que
tu traverses avec la barbe qu'éculée
ramène par ici
ce qui avec majan et ben oui c'est ce
que je lui dis on marque d'un autre côté
s'il a besoin de moi
alors ils m'ont fait part d'un fait s'il
sait qu'à l'heure qu'il est les
condamnés à mort
je sais bien mais s'il a besoin de moi
attention pensez vous pas faire de bruit
et à 20h le 6 février 1942
raymond toupet attendait qu'on lui fasse
depuis la rive opposée
le signal convenu il profité du voyage
pour amener une famille de
fonctionnaires qui regagnaient la zone
occupée
non c'est pas la peine je voulais déjà
dit je vais pas d'argent ni rien que je
puisse faire ce pas ainsi qu'on vous
serez de l'autre côté c'est mon fils qui
à vierzon chez sa grand-mère précis
alors achetez lui n'importe quoi quelque
chose une bricole ip portée du de ma
part mais moi je n'en sais rien c'est le
signal nous attendons maintenant à
l'hérésie
entraîné par le courant la barque à la
sécheresse sur l'autre rive en zone
libre
[Musique]
la famille affolé s'enfuir abandonnant
raymond à son sort
[Musique]
il
mais
[Musique]
on le découvrir aux premières lueurs de
l'aube elles ont pu constater qu'en
dépit de la températures glaciales qui
sévissent est son corps était encore
chaud la mort c'était sûrement fait
attendre dans cette interminable nuit
d'hiver qu'il avait recouvert d'un
linceul gym grand ouvert ses yeux bleus
fixait le ciel
[Musique]
oh
paris juillet 1940 le visage de paris
humilié cela allait durer quatre ans
[Musique]
dès les premiers jours de l'occupation
les allemands avaient procédé à
l'arrestation des sujets britanniques
qui résidait dans la capitale
certains cependant échappèrent à
l'internement en raison de leur
situation particulière
tel fut le cas du colonel cécile chaud
marié à une américaine
ancien commandant du 12e lanciers il
avait fait ses premières armes pendant
la guerre des boers delpy aussi le cas
de mr & line 2 devenu par son mariage
française et de surcroît comtesse et
bien l'air de 139 g soit il ment vieil
uniforme de la cre à 12 pour conduire un
convoi peut conduire à un convoi
d'ambulances aborde alors j'ai anem et
25 blessés a peur parce que nous étions
arrivés en même temps et les allemands
au milieu d'une pagaille et vous vous
imaginez et ato il était tout match
entier et après après je vais récupérer
mes enfants je suis rentré
voilà tout magueur enfin pollet moment
et vos colonel pour moi je ne change pas
j'avais toujours l'hôtel est
réquisitionnée par les allemands lui
parlait et genève où le directeur m'a
demandé de partir et je lui demandais
pourquoi je suis crayon dit si je reste
et je suis resté et ça ne vous gêne pas
de famille tous ces gars
seulement il a été nécessaire de changer
mes habitudes
maintenant je prends monter dans ma
chambre
et bien aujourd'hui vous les reprenez
chez moi aulas vraiment
jamais servi il avait un très bien c'est
une jeune fille maintenant on me direz
vous je vous en prie
et voilà au pied mon second pourra
jamais vous mais mais qu'est-ce que vous
avez tous les deuils rien c'est à dire
oh
vous les avez vous encore ramasser ces
deux là ne se fait que le centre notre
dame la nuit couche à l'armée du salut
mais qui n'ont pas droit d'y rester
pendant la journée
faudrait trouver des pantalons ils ont
mangé
oui c'est bien on est là dans votre
chambre et vous barinas chaîne techno a
été une maman que nous vous furent avec
ses 2 ou novembre
comme d'habitude au qui valait
s'accompagner à sauveterre de béarn mais
là on ne fera passer la nuit ensuite la
banque espagnole après après ils seront
arrêtés par les garde ce viol et notre
consulat par seconde on leur a dit mir
belgique par une guerre civile il
retourne l'arizona mahmoud que vous êtes
au courant je m'occupe aussi de cela
dites moi combien avez vous recueillez
transporter de ces prisonniers évadés
une quarantaine je pense c'est toujours
de sa profondeur comme cela pour que oui
[Musique]
un sergent si je crois vous savez où les
prenant comme il se présente nous ne
faisons pas le dire il faut et pourquoi
parce que nous sommes en guerre et à la
guerre en cela ce n'est qu'un homme
avait lui-même qui peut être remplacé
par un autre humain difficile c'est un
métier et ça coûte l'argentin au notaire
pour fabriquer un officier ils ne vont
pas tout mis l'argent à perdre c'est
pourquoi la consigne de londres est faux
mais priorité absolue aux hommes de
métier aux officiers un sergent aussi
c'est un homme de métier
oui mais ça coûte moins cher que
l'officier voulait vraiment et les
ordres de tel qu'un question à l'avenir
occupez-vous unique monde des garçons
que je vous présenterai et il fit le
passé la ligne vous même je compte sur
vous je ne sais pas très bien comment je
vais me prendre
bon c cnet regard vous savez pour gagner
une bataille il faut miser ce dieu cela
hasard et cela change à bien dormir
rodez a bien démarré le 20 novembre de
rester à ilan a des bonnes sécher à
colonel je n'ai jamais fait ça moi quand
tu as la chance ma première chance cette
finale coup de téléphone
alors oui comment allez vous je vous
remercie d'être venus aussi vous
permettez que je vous appelle maman sur
les appeler je sais que la croix rouge a
jamais été appelé en vain à votre
dévouement conclu avec toujours apporter
votre aide et que par conséquent nous
pouvons conditionne des cd marne tout le
monde contrairement à aujourd'hui avec
ou encore votre voiture
oui parfait voilà ce dont il s'agit vous
savez que pendant l'exode du mois
dernier
de nombreux enfants se sont trouvés
séparés de leurs parents les uns étant
maintenant en zone libre
les autres en zone occupée ou
inversement et bien nous avons besoin de
bonnes volontés
possédant une voiture pour emmener ses
enfants leurs familles bien entendu la
croix rouge vous fournira les bons
d'essence et aussi je suppose
le laissez-passer pas franchi la ligne
hélas non il faudra que chaque
convoyeuse l'obtiennent individuel bah
ouais je venais de me rappeler que je
connaissais un prince russe qui avait
toujours besoin d'argent et qui se
flatte d'être en excellents termes avec
les alliés et du moment figé promettait
de les plier il accepte tout de suite de
m'aider avec exactement dans une ado
l'étang de m'échanger je suis à vous et
je vous en prie je suis pas l'ombre
cela faisait tout de même quelque chose
de les voir installé comme chez eux à
l'hôtel clients puis je dois dire que
jamais un petit peu la frousse j'étais
d'accord mais est ce que j'allais en
soit et ouais
entré chez renée oget voilà je vous
présente à notre cher en tête madame la
comtesse
je vous en prie antilles où notre ami
m'a dit wood très intéressant dit et
c'est une oeuvre très belle très
philanthropiques et je vous félicite
je vous donnerai bien sûr toute facilité
pour transporter vos comment dit-on mots
vos petits protégés des volumes ainsi
trop heureux d'être agréable un ange de
bonté pour la hausse va se doubler le
lieutenant von bismarck que je vais le
prévenir
besma bismes avec un nom pareil c'est
sûrement un lieu plus siens eh bien pas
du tout il était très jolie gassot je
vous prie de m'excuser madame la
comtesse mais je dois inscrire votre
date de naissance
je vous en prie 25 juillet 1895 à la
note qui conduit votre voiture et moi
vous vous même mais bien sûr mais vous
êtes accompagné d'un chauffeur
je faire oui pour vous aider si vous
avez une panne ou ou changer une roue
mais comme je n'ai pas pensé à ça plus
tôt
vous vouliez un mécanicien oui c'est ça
un mécanicien je suis accompagné d'un
mécanicien c'était évident qu'elles sont
non son nom il faut que je l'écrive
c'est que là mon garçon vous me prenez
un peu des cours vous comprenez ce sont
des mécaniciens bénévoles qui font ça
pour aider la croix rouge est d'ailleurs
ce ne sera peut-être pas toujours les
mêmes qui m'accompagnera inscrivant
comme pas mieux de son mécanisme
voilà ce que raquel présente un carte
d'identité française même s'il n'avait
pas été aussi jeu les gars sont colorés
bien embrassait pourquoi le terreau
allemand games in the us lui il était
bien anglais ça se voyait tout de suite
cap 9 the wild card placé à boulogne est
évadé de l'hôpital de liège l'économie
charles avait chargé de tout un paquet
de l'enseignement a rapporté en
angleterre il allait être mon premier
mécanisme de lui quelques temps vous
mettais mon imagination à rude épreuve
bon allez au hasard dans l'annuaire
trideau je vais très bien ça fait
canadien michel
lionel est ce que michel qui vident
michel trudeau faire une profession
mécanicien nous croyons qu'il a choisi
de l'emploi
comme ça la moine d'espagne admettons
mais terrifiant
[Musique]
baby ont tous un peu de mémoire des
ducatistes holtby choix
[Musique]
e
alors quand allez-vous très bien très
bien avec lui obtenir sa maison aux
spurs
halloween est alors voilà il s'agit
d'aller chercher une petite fille à
limoges et de la ramener à pas c'est
d'ailleurs là l'icône going out
excusez moi une seconde you do you want
to write once you view id jette à l'eau
est ce que c'est moi vous disiez oui
j'étais en train de vous dire que
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
avoir les bons dix ans qu'on nous avait
promis nous avons eu un petit
contretemps le colonel madoff au
précieux la chancelière se joignent j'ai
choisi
[Musique]
si lé panneau je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya
ça n'avance jolie madame et monteur pas
d'habits d'expansion mais comment je
vais faire moi j'allais chercher un
enfant un petit enfant basse un enfant
et bbb baby à vous mais jolie madame il
faut pas pleurer
ice pegeen il m'en a jamais valley alors
je vais pas commencer des clôtures et
j'attendais mais cette fois ci pas très
longtemps
c'est un camion avec un soldat qui
s'était invité prouver que ce soit jimmy
j'ai pas pu l'empêcher de sortir
je crois bien que je n'ai jamais dit au
temps des grands mots de ma vie
enfin d'un clan démâtage et puis la
route avec -4 9 devant brad et nous
venons de dépasser la brouille
je suis là je n'en connais mario
madame fossé avec nous il faut passer
châteaudun oui vous pouvez amener montée
[Musique]
croix rouge française oui je suis de la
croix rouge française
[Musique]
vous savez accent anglais
j'ai été élevée par une haine
année
une raison claire
[Musique]
moi je reviens d'angleterre
j'ai aidé pour bombarder bristol jettent
a pu les juifs aiment poursuivie
jusqu'en france j'ai dû sauter en
parachute et maintenant je suis pieds et
vous parlez très bien le français
j'ai étudié à paris sorbonne un an avant
la guerre
ouais les offres spéciales
[Musique]
ian smith
na
un laitage nos goûts
m
c'est bien
baptiste very good et mécanique
[Musique]
ahmadi
ça se voit
qu'est-ce que vous je suis finalement je
n'avais pas les regrets d'avoir un
baquet cet aviateur parce que grâce à
lui nous avons franchi quelques barrages
sans encombre mais j'étais quand même
pas mal procédé m'en débarrasser voilà
nous sommes à châteaudun maintenant vous
pouvez continuer tout ça non vous allez
venir avec moi ou ça à la kommandantur
bon goût
[Musique]
c'est là y'a bon allez voir
as encore madame il faut venir mais
mais les grottes afghanes
[Applaudissements]
michael k de livres 29 suivi des deux
est l'âme du late show très tenir et
machines ou des légumes lfp de fiat
monsieur wada normandie ap quelque chose
obama mais si tu veux t'en aller je
crois qu'ils sont humains
madame total ce n'est que madame
seulement ange gardien de but
maël chaude celle de madame s'il vous
plaît
vous êtes très chantier pour notre
langue naturelle
ça c'est le preuve il y à des français
qui aiment les allemands passent et
madame prosit qu'est-ce que je peux
faire beaucoup madame pour vous
remercier vous de vous donner avec nous
koala voilà un ami à l'aide et peut-être
on peut donner un peu d'essence à peine
si ça fait vous plaisir
ça rendra service à la croix rouge
good gergaud voilà votre ticket ils sont
valables partout comme si votre voiture
est à 9 500 les trucs avec toutes mes
respects
attendez moi a tenté mois maintenant que
vous avez essence vous pouvez
accompagner mois aérodrome l'espace est
jaloux mais avec joie mais ce n'était
pas fini
la tête vers 9 h 45 locales
[Musique]
bah
cette fois vous êtes freine aller vers
ce n'est pas la peine que j'aille plus
loin si je veux vous présenter à mon
commandant et qu'il vous remercier lui
aussi aux marins
pauvreté mais une équipe n'a rien de ce
qui s'est passé je crois bien qu'il
nommait n'est pas l'enjeu pour voir
partir ses vues excusez ma commande à je
suis assez presseur vous ne voulez pas
manger avec nous je suis avec plaisir
mais d'ailleurs je ne suis pas seul j'ai
mon mécanicien avec moi et bien le
mécanicien il mangera décrit serge ans
avec les masi madame
ah oui ça c'est une chose non non je
vous assure ce n'est pas possible
alors vous ne refuserait pas de visiter
mon camp merci si je veux augmenter
venez nous voilà reparti les canadiens
étaient ici avant ils avaient tous très
très bien préparés maintenant c'est nous
qui sommes ici et c'est encore mieux
on nous a tout montré les agglomérations
cas les dépôts diminution les dépôts
d'essence avec toutes les explications
qui me comprenait toujours pas un mot
non il photographie d'un certain
elle s'intéresse à la matière de spam
[Musique]
enfin j'ai quand-même séoul quand nous
sommes revenus à la barrière
bon voyage vous avez loin l'image
dimon s'est résolu ce n'est pas facile
mais j'ai un achat même avec un aspect
davantage la démat actions privées et
permet depuis ce matin mais qu'on va
tomber en janvier quand les français
seront plus sage
alors on ne peut pas passer
on ne peut pas passer mais vous vous
passerez je vais téléphoner
deux heures plus tard nous sommes
arrivés à la ligne de démarcation
l'inspection de la voiture a duré une
éternité et je tremblais pour que les
commandants n'avait pas oublié ses coups
de téléphone de type quand un panneau à
noter seuls 250 marques se contrôler
dans le même temps ça correct
j'ai reçu permission au bout hoffmann
madame devine il restait au capitaine
james windsor lewis une longue route à
faire qui passant par l'espagne et le
portugal
le conduire est en angleterre d'où ils
repartiraient se battre devenu général
il termine à la guerre à lübeck
mais cette fois c'était lui l'occupant
quant à mary dinkle arrêté quelques
semaines plus tard elle devait passer
neuf mois en prison avant de reprendre
le combat clandestin arrêté de nouveau
sur la ligne de démarcation
grièvement blessé au cours d'une
tentative d'évasion
condamnée à mort elle vise à peine
commuée et fut déportée à ravensbrück
elle a sorti le 23 avril 1945 la tête
haute
en vraie fille d'albion
[Musique]
m
la ligne de démarcation n'était pas la
seule frontière tendus en travers du
territoire français à l'intérieur même
de la zone occupée
les allemands avaient institué au mépris
des conventions d'armistice après avoir
un excellent alsace et une partie de la
lorraine
une nouvelle ligne partant de
l'embouchure de la somme passant par
amiens la vallée de l'aisne saint dizier
doll est mauvaise pour aboutir au rhône
elle délimite est une zone dite
interdite dans la frontière occidentale
rappelé curieusement celle du
saint-empire romain germanique pesant
100 la capitale de la franche comté se
trouvait alors dans cette zone interdite
tout le poids de l'occupation se faisait
encore plus lourd les allemands et
entretenait une garnison de 25 mille
hommes et comme partout il avait
réquisitionné de nombreux édifices
publics y compris le troisième étage du
collège saint jean où était enfermé
leurs prisonniers malades ou blessés
anciens combattants de la grande guerre
remémore aux dirigeables tension à
résoudre résistance il a déjà été arrêté
une première fois quand la gestapo
l ao
l'alex quoi ces toilettes la wii amenez
le à la fenêtre
pendant la fenêtre qui sait
soit il ya peut-être
quelque chose
c'est moi alex on va te faire sortir
si vous êtes un clip à des styles vous
faut ici encore une lime evelyne aura
tout ça ce soir
à 9h03 le sait hardtois seulement pour
faire descendre une fille ciel quand on
sera là un d'accord
vous n'allez pas vous et pas des noms on
est occupé de ça tu veux bien bas du cul
permet ça nous regarde aussi nous on est
cinq là qu'on va sortir dans quelques
jours
batibouw terrier c'est sur les bulls
vont s'occuper de nous et c'est pas
demain la veille qu'on sortira pas vrai
qu'est ce que vous préférez qu'on soit
fusillés mais si vous vous classez c'est
nous qui seront fusillés notre peau elle
vaut bien là-bas autre nom et la salade
verte et ça va j'ai enfin les tracks là
il peut quand les distribuer ce soir
dans les boîtes aux lettres marqué ce
soir il ya mieux le faire mon vieux plus
important votre ac plus difficile et
puis surtout plus dangereux avant il
s'agit d'un agent belle qui fait le
courrier entre bruxelles et la frontière
espagnole
l'autre nuit s'est fait à ces zones et
au passage de la ligne sur la loue avec
le wef rafale de mitraillette dans
l'épaule et la jambe et ramassés par les
allemands ou l'envol est une des plus
belles tendance est inverse ou papier
qu'ils ont trouvé sur lui marqué ils ont
sûrement pas réussi à les déchiffrer
mais vous les connaissez vous pensez
bien qu'ils feront tout pour le faire
parler il faut pas qu'il parle on
comprenait ou est ce qu'il est au
troisième étage le sergent en
contournant vous allez voir la fenêtre
au dernier étage dans la club de
laâquiba déchu
j'ai vu la fenêtre qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme patrouilles et des patrouilleurs
fixe dans le quartier on absolument pas
y'a pas de patrouille spécialement
affectés à saint jean il y avait pas
trop de normes à l'envi et le porche ses
gardes et non les allemands occupent le
troisième étage où travaille à la riaj à
m la médecin finale devant le porche par
contre une sentinelle devant la salle à
l'intérieur on croise des fenêtres qui
sont dessous peuvent le voir aucun les
couloirs moi je pense que c'est pas
suivre seulement il n'est pas tout seul
il ya également avec lui un agent secret
français
bon pour le poteau mais aussi est un
prisonnier évadé qui voudraient bien
peau retournée dans son stalag ah ouais
ça fait trois salles et dans un sens
c'est pas plus mal pour ont cédé et ce
serait pour ce soir avant 9 heures ça ne
laisse pas beaucoup de temps de parcours
c'est bien c'est bien mais la gestapo de
dijon a déjà réclamé le belge s'ils
viennent le chercher demain c'est
terminé pour lui
par la fenêtre mais du barreau balayer
tout ce qu'il faut non c'est pas ça qui
nous a guidés de ma soeur c'est surtout
pour tous ceux qui restent on voudrait
pas que préféré faire ça dans une autre
pièce qu'on puisse pour les soupçonner
de nous avoir aidés ne peut pas sortir
dès le seroc une sentinelle à la porte a
été justement pour ça qu'on pense à la
petite pièce a coûté et où seuls des
moteurs voilà comment vous pouvez nous
aider
ce soir ou lui donner un bon somnifère
comme ça il ne verra même pas il m'a
matin si on l'interrogé se souviendra
plus de rien et vous vous serez là pour
témoigner qu'ils pouvaient pas nous
entendre services que vous me demandez
là dont je viens de faire il faut qu'ils
soient d'accord je lui posais la
question et après comme ans après we une
faction dehors qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
mais c'est madame brûlant c'est prévu et
les beats pas loin elle accepte de les
garder pour la nuit et puis il m'a
battle.net eu enfin passer la ligne avec
son garage et ouais mais ce qu'il faut
d'abord maintenance à les faire sortir
vous avez du monde j'ai deux petits gars
qui demandent quatre ans de routine et
puis j'ai pensé que vous de votre côté
vous pourriez je vends mon frère dicky
son passage
ouais au troisième étage avec la
citadelle t'es juste à côté et que vous
vexe je préside et de rencontres
c'est comme ça ils ont pas choisi comme
instituteur s'embarrasser de quoi la
question dans ce marché qui tarde 11h
alors ton site et du matériel au jour
par la drôme et de quelle longueur il
leur faudrait sept cordes ont 22
maintenant là ils font troisième vous
voulez les faire descendre par la façade
vu que c'est plus simple ya pas de
sentinelle en bas et puis sa vie il
vaudra mieux être armés moreau il fait
ce qu'il veut moi je le saurai c'est
quoi leur nez ou 9 heures tout ce petit
square de lens agen
henry
qui donc c'était toujours d'accord c'est
pour ce soir bien sûr que je suis
d'accord qu'est ce qu'on va faire je
penserai chez toi vers 9h30 avec les
instructions
je te préviens c'est pas du plateau
voilà passe par derrière porte ma mère
ta voix pâte à caracas a pu ouvrir la
porte
ok ça lui et le soir même à 9 heures
nos trois amis l'a retrouvée dans le
petit square c'est authentique logement
compte et où le revenant ya peu de
chances qu'ils viennent se balader par
ici un manque de distraction qu'un
accord minutes où dorment des socios né
à temps
ça y est
oui il dort pas de chance
[Musique]
tiens pour la même fenêtre
mon dieu regardez
eh bien oui je vous le dis soit ils sont
tous dehors on va se faire piquer alors
allons donner votre avis
préval
11h20 non c'est trop tôt la dernière on
est à une heure
pour combien de temps à élise là haut
que la dernière ronde est pas vain une
heure du matin ils peuvent pas finir les
barreaux avant je croyais pourtant que
ça aurait fini avant le couvre-feu
non c'est pas possible on reconnaît un
problème c'est que les puits qui m'ont
lâché ces messieurs sur moi si je suis
pas en train mais lui n'en fait pas
maintenant quand robin mains avec rené
mon frère est votre petit cas là c'est
pour faire le boulot
j'aurai pour trimestre avec nous soyez
tranquilles tout ira bien
oui c'est un ferme à quoi j'ai dû
pousser le verrou comme ça m'a
finalement annonce a renchéri rarement
bien entendu jean l'attraper ah non moi
m'a semblé jeu rien entendu les bonnets
ou ne veuille pas trop tard non non je
tue j'arrive du foot avec une fille
t'es con c'est ma mère elle a
rendez-vous à 1h30 en bas de chez moi
[Musique]
m
on va s'y attacher
[Musique]
on fait porter vous
cette nuit
les saints sont révélés semaine avec
qu'est ce que c'est du bluff wayne c'est
pour dépister les chiens si jamais les
allemandes des fous deux res il ya
partout en mer découverts ben bravo
c'est discret comme signal
bon toi rené tu restes avec moi vraiment
mettre m labatut gâteau francs et si les
allemands arrivent comment je te
préviens la chouette
d'accord vous devant rester ici avec le
blessé est en bas vont rappliquer vu
aller
[Musique]
voici peut-être juste on n'a pas eu le
temps de célébrer bateau enfin donc je
puisse plier bagage elle essaye encore
non non je bois trop bien placer mon
plat est fou voici la raison mais ça se
passe pas comme ça ces trucs là il
faudra un bon signe pour coupet on en a
pas j'avais ce projet mais ce n'est pas
si c'est pas inquiet de garder que
l'autre appelle les allemandes aura
l'air malin
qu'est ce qui peut bien [ __ ]
on n'a pas resté là 107
je vois mal nos vies mais c'est mal un
ballon mais reporté
c'est
ça c'est sûr ils ont dû se faire piquer
je crois que c'est cuit
bon ben alors on se tire à temps
vous
tu me gêne tout jeune la regarde plus
tôt ou donnés mais bon
allez vous savez 1
aléatoire non elle est à toi mon naughty
dog c'est pas le moment des vies des
vases et je regarde comment je suis
généreux rebelles n'ont regardé comment
je fais
l'accord des gens comme ça oui s
compter que sur bâtard yves tapia
[Applaudissements]
bret
il est complètement touré
jean bart
que ça paie
[Musique]
c'est plus un poil de sec
ça va marcher de parler vu ça
je commençais à m'inquiéter réfugiés
avant minuit près du retard alors quoi
merde tu décides - coutin cible pour les
voit pas il ya qu'à laisser tomber non
c'est pas possible un type calais fois
c'est trop dangereux va pas laisser
tomber aux mains des salles non
seulement nous aborder absolument
qu'elle sorte de la twa c'est pourquoi
les îles encore cela qu'est ce qui vous
arrive à simplement maintenant âgé la
drouille quoi voilà j'ai la trouille je
vois pas ça se commande pas un peu de
courage que diable
le camarade était blessé ils l'ont bien
fait oui le risque avec l'usiné un pas
moi alors je reste
qu'est ce qu'il fout merde mais les
allemands vont vous remplir votre
stalock et ben j'y retournerais et puis
la guerre s'arrêtera bien un jour un
menu est vivant
allez allez allez monter mais qu'est-ce
qui m'a menti on peut même parler mais
il va rentrer ou alors moi j'appelle la
sentinelle quitte à vous voulez très
bien j'y vais j'y vais pas
c'est pas trop tôt
comme prévu les trois évadés pu repasser
en zone libre
quant à ceux qui avaient risqué pour le
moins la liberté en les énormes ouvrez
la leur ils recuire dès le lendemain
leur vie tranquille anonyme et
apparemment sans histoire henry ce que
tu as fait tes tennis on va quoi ça cela
quand même tu pourrais faire attention
tu sais des tennis comme ça tu n'en
trouvera plus même avec des tickets à
les oublier qu'au sens inverse quand ans
que je te dis et oui ma chère maman
c'est la guerre
[Musique]
il
m
allemand
[Musique]
un an
on
[Musique]
je